So if you're not new here,
you know that I like to cook everything sourdough.
I'm a stay at home mom
and do all of the cooking at home.
But on the times when I'm not home,
I need something in the pantry,
a quick backup
for my husband to cook something for the kids.
So I came across this.
Just a sourdough pancake mix.
I wanna give it a try.
I went with the original one today,
as I have some buttermilk
leftover for making raw butter yesterday
and I wanted to use it up before it went bad.
So at this point,
my husband would probably just use water,
as he wouldn't know buttermilk from his elbow.
But anywho, we're gonna throw in four eggs
and give that a mix.
At this point,
I'd already made a nice stack of pancakes,
but my son requested some chocolate chips,
so I threw those in.
And. Delightful.
I would definitely recommend.
She has a great ingredients list.
Go check Jess's out on TikTok.
Kid approved.